[Music]
these two are getting married in moscow
today
both of them wearing a dress the
students say they want to make a
statement
for tolerance love and freedom the
couple and many of their guests write
for the critical moscow student magazine
doxa
including yekaterina the 25 year old has
been an editor for the online platform
for two years
she says this wedding has raised her
spirits
at the moment it seems like everyone
hates each other the government hates us
and there is political repression
everywhere
but here there is love everywhere and
that's important
but there's a serious reason for the
joyous celebration
the couple is marrying so they can't be
forced to testify against each other in
court
natalia kishkevich and three other doxa
journalists
have been accused of inciting minors to
take part in unauthorized anti-kremlin
protests
an investigation is ongoing for months
now they have only been allowed to leave
their homes for two hours a day
they could face up to three years in
prison
yes suggestion is now to be honest i
don't understand what danger the
authorities see in a student magazine
but i guess there must be something
after all we have managed to build up an
extremely strong community of
free-thinking people
it's probably enough that we have
created a sort of grassroots initiative
with very horizontal structures and
without hierarchies
such as something strange
incomprehensible and scary for the
authorities
earlier this year doxa reported about
russia-wide protests in support of
arrested opposition politician
alexey navalny it criticized russian
universities for pressuring students to
stay home
and not take part in demonstrations
like other media outlets doxa then faced
police searches and arrests
students and young people came out in
solidarity with the journalists
but pressure on the critical media is
growing across russia
several media outlets have been declared
foreign agents
meanwhile at an economic forum in june
vladimir putin had only praised for the
state of freedom of speech
we have so many news channels in russia
so many internet channels
so many different opinions in the media
you hear such critical opinions
topics and assessments of the government
as well as of yours truly
i don't think such harsh criticism
exists in many countries
and all these journalists are just
continuing their work
nothing is happening to them
is visiting someone who would disagree
with that vladimir mitsulkin is one of
four journalists from the student
magazine doxa who could face prison
since april he has been under de facto
house arrest
the 26 year old isn't allowed to use the
internet
and can only leave his house for two
hours a day he has to wear an electronic
ankle monitor it was already clear that
this steamroller was rolling over more
and more people
and putting pressure on them and that at
some point it would get to us
when this whole thing started in april
the trees were still there
and i thought oh well i guess i'll just
sit inside then
but then you see that it's spring and of
course you just want to be outside
vladimir lives with his mother a russian
human rights organization has designated
him
and the other three doxa journalists
with ankle tags
as political prisoners yekaterina is
trying to keep them involved in the work
of the magazine
any of us could have ended up in their
place the fact that they got unlucky
was just a
[Music]
despite the political pressure around 30
students currently write for doxa
since the police search they haven't had
an office mostly they discussed their
work online
they say that is usually safer
when the police searched our office i
thought a lot about why i'm so scared
but i'm not leaving i came to the
conclusion that it doesn't really matter
what job i do
if the people at the top want to
persecute us they will no matter what
journalism has become a crime in russia
everything you do
everything you publish is seen by the
authorities as an attack or a threat
discrimination lgbtqi rights corruption
the students reporting hardly tows the
official line
today they're taking new photos since
the criminal case against them the
magazine has gained a lot of new readers
that gives you katarina hope
the fire that pushes journalists to work
isn't going out
i don't want to cross journalism in
russia off my list completely
if there are no other magazines or media
outlets left where i feel free
then we'll just have to start a new one
that will probably also be closed and
declared a foreign agent
but that's just the reality at the
moment
it's a reality yekaterina says the
journalists at doxa want to face they
say all those who dare to be critical in
russia
have to make sure to stick together
you